وين مشان الله للعالم كله مش ملاق حدا
يطعمنا يا الله هذه صرخات الاب اليائسه
الذي لم يتبقى له الا صوته اب لم يعد
قادرا على حمايه اطفاله الثلاثه
الضعفاء مش قادر اعيش داري مش بلاق اكل
حداق جبي ما حدا عمللي حاجه تفضلوا شوفوا
يا ناس شوفوا بق في السياره كل الليل وانا
وانا بنقلهم من الخيمه للخيمه هذ اطلعوا
يا ناس شوفوا الاولاد يا ناس لاكثر من 60
يوما حاول ان يظل
قويا حتى وصل الى نقطه لم يعد قادرا فيها
على
ذلك اطفاله المعاقون مشردون وجياع متمون
من حرب
غزه ماذا تفعل عندما يحتاج طفلك اليك ولم
يبقى لديك ما تعطيه و اروح يا ناس مشان
الله ارحمونا يقول ابو
محمد لا رحمه لاهل هذه الارض المحاصره على
ما يبدو والمطر الذي كانوا يقولون عنه انه
نعمه لا يجلب الان سوى المزيد من الياس
بالنسبه لاولئك الذين اجبروا على ترك
منازلهم اصبحت الحياه الوع البائس حيث
تغمر الامطار مخيماتهم المؤقته انه فصل
الشتاء القاسي الذي بدا
لتو وتطلع ام علي على الخيمه الصغيره التي
تعيش فيها مع 11 اخرين ابنتيها واحفادها
هذا
الخيمه الخي امضت الليل وهي تحاول التقاط
المطر الذي تساقط عبر سقف ماواهم
الهشك
لاق يا تم عند الطلعه
كميم مش
قادره دورنا نهدد في غزه حرق ومحرق ما
فيشنا متوى ما فيش نا حاجه نعيش فيش كيف
بنا نم احنا اقول لك من بره الوضع اللي
كنا نلاقي الميه ونقول الحمد لله والله يا
رب نحب ه النعمه نحب الشتاء ونموت عليه
والله بس الوقت اللي ننا فيه صي مش قادرين
قادرين المره مين ب هذ اطلع كيف مين
ب انه امر كبير جدا لا يستطيع الاباء
والامهات تحمله عندما لا تتمكن حتى من
ابقاء اطفالك جافين ودافئ ونظيف مع بدء
انتشار الامراض والمساعدات التي يحتاجون
اليها بشده اصبحت الان سلاحا في هذه
الحرب نحفظ عليهم البرد والسقعه ماي معي
القصف والدمار والبرد سقعه كمان والعيا
الحمد لله على كل حال الحمد لله بدي احافظ
عليهم ان تكون اما او ابا في غزه نعمه
تحولت الى عذاب بالنسبه لاولئك الذين لم
يعودوا يتساءلون اذا بل كيف سيموتون هم
وابنائهم يقول ابو محمد انه كان جالسا
يفكر في كيفي
عندما ضربت غه انا انا وين اروح انا
واولادي انا نازح من الشاطئ اجيت على الر
بدي اموت بالدير الامين اريهم ربيت عيني
ايش اللي بصير فينا يا عمي مثل كثيرين في
غزه فانهم لا يلومون اسرائيل فقط بل
يريدون من حماس ان توقف الحرب الذين
يدفعون ثمنها مهجور وحيدون فالعالم لن
يوقف الامهم لان البالغه من العمر ست
سنوات تحت انقا منزلها لمده ثلاه ايام بس
ب ماما
[موسيقى]
انا ان تكون ابا او اما في غزه يعني ان
تعيش في خوف من هذا انك لن تعود موجودا
عندما يكونون في امس الحاجه
اليكان كراش سي ان
لندن